[Musique]
il y as est un élément de ces mesures
qui sont difficiles à mettre en oeuvre
en afrique quand on sait qu'une bonne
partie de la population n'a pas accès à
l'eau ni à des savons et c'est celui-là
que ces mesures doivent être accompagnés
d'autres interventions dans les
quartiers précaires
c'est par exemple s'assurer qu'on met
des points d'eau a réparti dans les
quartiers qu'on assure par exemple une
distribution de savons donc c'est tous
ces éléments qui doivent faire partie
d'un plan de réponse le prends le plan
de réponse à une épidémie doit aussi
tenir en compte le contexte particulier
de là où sévit cette épidémie ajustée
cette réponse là au contexte africain
indispensable
les familles dans les pays africains
dépendent essentiellement de l'économie
informelle et vont devoir trouver des
moyens de subsistance pour pour
continuer de vivre normalement
donc ces mesures restrictives
nécessaires pour contrôler l'épidémie
doivent être accompagnées de mesures
économiques et sociales comme notamment
des compensations financières pour les
familles qui seront en isolement et qui
ne pourront pas continuer de travailler
et
[Musique]
nous pensons qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire lorsque nous voyons les
messages qui circulent dans sur les
réseaux sociaux
il semble que cette prise de conscience
n'est pas encore effective il y a
beaucoup de travail a fait une
sensibilisation à faire en afrique les
cas qui augmente les desserts que nous
observons ne confirme pas tous ses
mythes qu'on a par rapport à la
résistance f2 de personnes vivant en
afrique par rapport aux aspects de
climat nous pouvons on pourrait avoir
une épidémie beaucoup plus graves avec
des conséquences beaucoup plus graves
dans certains pays
nous avons nettement à une létalité au
dessus de ce que nous avons observé en
chine et donc il faut fait absolument
attention il faut prendre conscience et
non encourage d'ailleurs tous les
groupes sociaux tous les leaders
politiques les leaders réligieux à jouer
leur rôle dans cette sensibilisation
[Musique]
c'est absolument indispensable
pas seulement pour les médicaments mais
également pour le personnel expérimenté
qui connaît déjà la gestion de cette
crise et qui pourra venir en aide aux
houblons ministère de la santé au
gouvernement
il faut absolument que ces personnes là
puissent circuler entre les pays il ya
des intrants de laboratoires qui sont
fabriqués à l'extérieur il ya des
équipements de protection pour protéger
le personnel médical et pour permettre
une prise en charge efficace il y a tous
ces équipements en les concentrateurs
d'oxygène les appareils pour à pour
soutenir la respiration lorsqu'on a une
détresse respiratoire qui sont pas du
tout fabriqué en afrique et pour
lesquels la solidarité est nécessaire
mais nous pensons aussi que des des
privés des industries devraient aussi
s'engager pour l'afrique par solidarité
il faut dire que même si la maladie
incontrôlée ailleurs tant qu'on a encore
des foyers de l'autre côté du monde
on reste toujours à risque entre le
centre de la chine où la transmission
locale
un pratiquement arrêté mais on continue
d'avoir des cas importés
donc la solidarité pour un contrôle
mondial est nécessaire
[Musique]